non-minimalists
all right denzel wants to know is it
possible to be a minimalist
as a teenager you know what our audience
before our documentary came out
skewed to be more our age you know you
and i are
37 well you're almost 37
and um how dare you and uh you know
a lot of people in our audience were you
know 35 to 55 years old
and since our documentary came out
especially since we're doing more stuff
on
youtube i've noticed a lot of people
showing up to our events
who are in college or are in high school
yeah
and we're seeing more and more people
who are
young who are being influenced because
they're realizing the perils
of their parents ways of living
i wish i would have known about
minimalism in high school man or you
were a teenager
yeah i wish i wish i would have well
knowing about it and connecting with it
the way i do
are two separate things right but i wish
i knew about it and connected
uh with it the way i do now because in
high school man there are so many
pressures whether it's
wearing the right you know pair of shoes
or pair of jeans
i mean my dad would never let me wear a
pair of jenko jeans but i wanted them so
bad in high school
why wouldn't he let you wear them
because they were worldly and that's
aren't levi's worldly too yeah dude
that's that's a whole other conversation
man worldly basically means that you're
not a jehovah's witness
um and and yes those were too worldly it
looked worldly but anyway
uh the pressures though of having you
know not just the right um
the right uh clothing but listening to
the you know i was make sure that i was
a fan of the right
uh you know the right uh uh band or
group or singer song whatever man like
there are all these pressures
that we have in high school these
preferences really
that are forced on us other people's
preferences yeah so they're forced on us
through
uh you know the kids that that they were
forced on me
through the kids i went to school with
they were also forced on me through
advertisements media yeah through the
media so
having all of this pressure of other
people's preferences
minimalism would have been great to help
me filter through all those preferences
to really figure out
what it was that would have added value
to my life as a teenager because dude
i'm so glad i'm not in high school
anymore dude i like
some people look back like man i really
misses high school i do not miss high
school
i do not miss being confused i do not
miss
uh not being able to decide on my own
preferences but i do like to think that
if i
again would have connected with
minimalism like i do now
that maybe it would have been a little
bit better for me a little bit less
hectic
i agree i i think that when i think
about
you know the the high school years and
and my preferences
and they were often dictated by other
people's expectations but guess what
that also happened in my 20s
and it would have continued to happen in
my 30s and my 40s and my 50s other
people's expectations
what i've learned from a lot of our
events that were going on when these
teenagers are showing up
it used to be that like parents were
dragging their teenagers to our events
and now we have teenagers dragging
their parents to the event in fact our
event in louisville
recently um we were we were doing the
the vip event beforehand where we
have like a little 45 minute discussion
with a small group of 20 to 50 people
who
who have the best seats in the house
basically and
um we we're just having this
conversation i'm giving this really good
talk about
your minimalism i feel really good about
also i turn around
and my former boss is there jeff moore
he hired me when i was 18 years old he's
the first person to hire me in a telecom
and man i about cracked my pants like i
was like
oh my goodness here's the guy who you
know ruined my life for 12 years
he didn't actually actually what jeff
did was he instilled some serious
extroversion skills in me because i was
such a shy
extreme introvert that without him
taking me on board and
forcing me to talk to people via sales
and retail sales and door-to-door sales
and all this other stuff
i would not have been able to
communicate with people the way that i
do now because
i was so introverted there's no way
i would have been able to break the
spell on my own i needed that push at
first and so
the push for me was like was the full
immersion into that and he helped me
do that and afterward we were talking
and it was his 22 year old daughter
emily who who dragged him there
from cincinnati down to louisville to
come to our event
and and you know she had found us when
she was in college and
watched a documentary and read the books
and she was talking to him about our
books and our blog and our podcast and
he's like you really know these guys
like and he brought me some old pictures
of me when i was 18. i had my head
shaved and
um i was a mess i was wearing a suit i
looked like a
like a preacher from did you put any of
those on instagram
no i i brought the pictures home though
so i probably should that'd be good that
would be funny give i'll give them the
jess for um
throwback thursday instagram stories
she'll enjoy that
but my whole point is it used to would
back in the day would have been someone
like jeff
bringing his daughter there and saying
see you can be a minimalist too and now
what i'm seeing are people like emily
who are showing their parents like hey i
know you've lived this one way
and i'm not telling you to change your
life what i'm telling you is
we can always simplify and for me that's
the number one lesson of minimalism
no matter where you are age-wise you
could be young or
old no matter where you are in the
socio-economic ladder rich or poor you
and i have been both and we've been in
between
no matter where you are with respect to
your age your
socio-economic status your social class
no matter where you are geographically
no matter what your ethnicity is we see
people from
all walks of life that are at our events
minimalism
really applies to one group of people
people who are dissatisfied with
whatever the status quo
is and they want to make a change they
want to simplify
and so if you're a teenager and you're
unhappy with what the status quo
is then yes but also if you're a senior
citizen
and you're unhappy with what the status
quo is then yes i think minimalism can
apply to you
if you're anyone in between and you're
unhappy with where the status quo is
in your life then yes then maybe
simplifying a little bit
is right for you